When you think of
assessments in education,
you probably think of what we
call summative assessments.
These are things like tests and quizzes
that occur at the end of some learning
process, to see whether or not you
learned the material by some deadline.
And you take the assessment, you find
out if you passed or failed, and
you move forward either way.
But wouldn't it be great to find out
while you're learning if you're learning
the material well enough?
That's where formative
assessment comes in.
Formative assessment is assessment while
you're learning some new material.
And it's really powerful,
because it more authentically mimics
the way we learn in the real world.
When you're learning to walk or talk,
what you're really doing is trying
lots of things every single minute and
getting immediate feedback on whether or
not you did it correctly.
That's formative assessment.
It's assessment while you're
trying to learn something.
So formative assessment
is very powerful, and
I would say it's
universally a good idea.
The difficulty is it's very difficult
to do in a regular classroom.
When you have one teacher and
20 or 30 students,
how do you have that one
teacher give all those students
individual feedback on what they're
doing wrong all at the same time?
It just can't be done.
And a college classroom
is even more difficult.
You have one professor and
200 or 300 students.
How can they give 200 students
feedback all at the same time?
It's just not possible.
That's why we talk about this in
an educational technology class.
Educational technology
can help us with that.
Educational technology can develop tools
to give students individual feedback on
what they're doing
while they're doing it.
We can use artificial intelligence
to give every single student
some individualized feedback on what
they did wrong on that latest iteration
all at the same time, even if everyone
is doing something different.
So that's why we talk
about it in this class.
So in this lesson, we'll talk about
what formative assessment is,
why it's powerful, and
how we can develop educational
technologies that help facilitate it.